welcome back i am so excited to have
these ladies in our kitchen today
they're adding some deliciousness to
daytime with their brand new show the
good dish and there are roommates across
the hall at their studio please welcome
daphne oz gail simmons and jamika
passova
[Applause]
i was so excited i came and crashed your
premiere show that was wild by the way
we were so focused on like everything we
need to know it's like our it was our
basically our first day on the job
and you just showed up with the tuna
casserole and yet you guys are such
veterans and i was like i hope this is
okay
you know no one's okay
noodle casserole and make you feel like
the most welcome it was far and away the
nicest most lovely gesture i've never
gotten to have a big sister it was like
the most sisterly move ever it was so
sweet
thank you
well i'm just so glad that you guys are
here you're having this beautiful show
that you're making it feels so right
what everybody needs right now beautiful
cooking
friendship you know interesting guests
great conversations
but when it comes to food i can't think
of three more extraordinary women and i
would be silly not to ask you guys if
you would teach us something to cook yes
[Applause]
so we're going to do a bacon egg and
cheese croissant casserole
it's great for a brunch it's great to
celebrate with people that you love it's
just a wonderful fun dish to do and
you'll see how easy it is so i'm so
excited to learn how to make this
classic sort of turned on its head
you'll see it's very straightforward so
we're starting with just day old
croissants and this is a great like
rehash if you have i don't know what
kind of person you are if you have old
leftover croissants but they should have
been eaten the first day but if you have
them left over you just slice them in
half and this is how you're going to
rehydrate them i have gorgeous
caramelized onions here add such a nice
base of flavor and just spoon it right
over top of your croissants and then
once you have your onions lovingly
ladled over top of your croissants go
ahead and sprinkle on some shredded
cheddar cheese and some crumbled
broccoli and the knowledge that you can
get bacon
[Laughter]
you know what if you were so inclined
you could easily sneak some vegetables
into this this dish which we're not
doing now jamaica you have two daughters
we're both in the two girl clubs yes
one and five so yeah my house is bananas
every single look at those little babies
oh my goodness all right so now we have
the base of this yummy casserole built
which again was our croissants our
caramelized onions our bacon our cheddar
cheese and now it's time for the custard
which is what's going to saturate it
bring it back to life revive it give you
that amazing pillowy texture underneath
and then crispy bits on top am i
speaking your language
[Applause]
okay so we have the base and in a big
bowl i've broken eight eggs and i've
whisked them really well with milk and
then of course jimmy can help me season
that always season your eggs that's
right forget that tip see i already did
that good i got yeah i got salt in there
salt and pepper milk and eggs and i'm
just gonna pour
this custard base
right over
the croissant you really want to make
sure it's covered until it cooks evenly
that's right
and then
because you always have to be a little
extra in the good dish kitchen jamaica
do you want to top it off with daphne
put the let me throw the top right
that's right because we only have the
bottoms of the croissants so you'll use
those and just kind of squish that down
into that egg mixture all cements are
forgiven in casseroles just so we're
clear there we go and by the way kitchen
recovery is something else i'm big on
because there shouldn't be stress in the
kitchen it's a place to come and be free
relax experiment think of how few places
there are as an adult that you can truly
pick up something new with so little
risk like get in there make what your
family loves make what you love make it
your own don't stress there's always
some recovery right here that's fine
that's perfect
i like that yeah that's a great move
yeah that's a good technique i don't
know what i'm doing she's a natural she
was technically
i probably should have put the cheese in
before that and now it's now i'm gonna
oh there's more cheese just put more
cheese on top just like it can never be
too much cheese that's the beauty of
this dish like come on yeah so cover it
with a little cheese all right there you
go right over i'm already going rogue
guys darn it fine
exactly thank you there she is thank you
exactly definitely so no more cheese now
the star of this dish you don't want to
miss this part we have the cheese we
have the croissants eggs the bacon all
of that everything bagel seasoning if
you don't have this in your pantry you
are missing out it just adds literally
everything you get that garlic you the
sesame seed it's like that bite that
you're missing it's like that bagel
this makes my morning and you don't have
to as much as you want to do i mean i
even kind of snack on this sometimes
don't tell anybody because it's so good
everything big i'm sure no one can
relate to being in a kitchen just doing
something like that last night i had
like a kids cabinet for their snacks
okay but i'm always
always
the later it gets the more likely i am
to end up in that cabinet it's so true
stacy's pita chips was what oh i woke up
with on my bedside table
[Laughter]
no judgment so this is going to go into
the oven yes we're going to put it into
the oven how long what temp so we're
going to cover it and tuck it in a 350
oven for about 50 minutes then uncover
it and let it get golden brown for
another 20 minutes and then we shall
dine when we come back
[Music]